Welcome to homework 5.
In the first problem, you're going to build some intuition for what happens to a robot's path
when one of the these parameters, either toe p, toe d, or toe i, is set equal to 0,
so if we don't include that term in our steering angle equation.
In each of these 4 cases on the left, the black horizontal line is the intended track for the robot,
while the pink represents its actual motion.
In each of these cases, the robot has a 10 degree positive drift
and starts with a cross check error of 1.
For each of these 4 cases, you should go through and decide which of these radio buttons
is the correct selection.
So for example, if you thought that this was appropriate robot motion
and all the parameters were tuned correctly,
you would select no problem.
Keep in mind that each column should be selected exactly 1 time. Good luck!